bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
l'armée israélienne affirme avoir mené
une opération antiterroriste en
cisjordanie dans le viseur le hamas le
mouvement islamiste est il vraiment une
menace pour pour tel-aviv dans ces zones
qui sont quand même assez éloigné de la
bande de gaza
je ne crois pas que d'un point de vue
militaire ou sécuritaire directement le
hamas comme d'éventuels autres groupes
armés palestiniens
constitue une véritable menace pour le
taïso rien disons que ce qui se passe
depuis
les affrontements militaires du mois de
mai en gros chaque mois il y à des
attaques il y a
vous avez mentionné le dernier en date
mais il y en a eu d'autres précédemment
de l'armée nigérienne qui désormais tirs
à balles réelles et cela également lors
de manifestations pacifiques contre des
installations des colonies israéliennes
dans les territoires occupés en
cisjordanie
particulièrement avec un lot important
de morts et blessés côté palestinien
mais je passe plus largement qu'il faut
voir ce qui se passe aussi dans la
logique des deux camps c'est à dire à
l'intérieur du camp palestinien il ya
d'un côté le président mahmoud abbas qui
ces derniers jours a déclaré à
l'assemblée générale des nations-unies
que les rayons pourraient encore une
année de temps pour se retirer ramallah
territoires palestiniens comme c'est
long
les selon le droit international
faute de quoi ils remettraient la clé de
l'autorité palestinienne ce qui fait
bien sûr sourire les autorités
israéliennes
mais en même temps si vous regardez de
complémentarité entre l'action
diplomatique de l'autorité palestinienne
et le travail du hamas sur le terrain
qui est bien une résistance armée contre
l'occupant israélien il ya là une
complémentarité une rivalité entre le
fatah de mahmoud abbas et le hamas côté
ils reviennent par contre on voit très
bien comment le nouveau premier ministre
nathalie pernette doit
montrer
avec la force des armes sa position
politique à l'égard des palestiniens
et cela il le fait à n'ayant et guère à
ce que le likoud de netanyahou et ses
alliés
comporte comme opposition et risque à la
permanence du gouvernement de coalition
formé par naftali bennet
lapide
et c'est donc
on peut lire c'est ces périodiques
escalade de violence comme étant à la
fois de l'ordre de la pérennisation du
conflit qui deviennent de plus en plus
être mais également des rapports de
force à l'intérieur de chaque camp alors
justement vous avez parlé de naftali
bennett et de sa politique sur le plan
sécuritaire aujourd'hui quelle est la
marge de manoeuvre pardon de la
communauté internationale pour essayer
justement de trouver une solution à ce
conflit qui dure entre les palestiniens
et les israéliens
d'arrêter
disons le principal médiateur pourrait
être enfin reconnue en tout cas comme le
sommier dia totalisé vrille assez bien
les états unis les états unis de baden
n'ont pas trop envie de s'impliquer dans
le conflit donc il y à
des mesures
adoptées par l'administration bei den du
style ouvrir une représentation
américaine à jérusalem est
mais il n'y a rien de concret enfin
restaurée également une partie de l'aide
américaine aux palestiniens mais il n'y
a rien de concret concernant
les l'occupation israélienne on a vu un
corps de l'autre jour la continuation du
finacement iron dôme le système de
défense israélien qui est un système de
défense cofinancé par les américains et
le complexe militaire israélien donc la
position américaine
continue de de camper en quelque sorte
sur l'imposition pro-israélienne côté
union européenne il y a comme
habituellement des déclarations mais sur
le plan pratique
l'union européenne est incapable
d'imposer une volonté quelconque
reste les voisins arabes sinon la ligue
des états arabes qui elle aussi de ce
point de vue est assez inexistant merci
beaucoup en tout cas ricardo a beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
sociologie politique à l'institut des
hautes études internationales et du
développement et spécialiste du moyen
orient